[Applaudissements]
julien salut les terriens
c'est quand tu as le plessis à l'école
ola a eu un mec ou quand gabin et son
bac
alors on va rappeler qui est parce que
lola c'est ma fille 19 et gabin c'est
mon fils 17 stèles mémoire j'ai le plus
pleurer quand mon fils a eu son bac
parce que c'était vraiment inespéré
[Applaudissements]
à aucun moment il a douté je suis dit tu
peux pas l'avoir ce n'est pas possible
dans ces conditions c'est même plus ça
serait surnaturel j'aurais il est ce que
tu penses de [ __ ] qui reportent leur
mariage pour un match de foot au à dori
dit c'est parce que donc je devais me
marier 1 dimanche soir en 98 et je
commence à voir je ne pense pas une
seconde que l'équipe de france d'aller
en finale et en avance dans la
compétition elle va aller en finale donc
je dis je vais me marier le soir de la
finale de coupe du monde il y aura
personne ou alors ils vont tous être
avec des draps la saumure donc je les
réussis à tout reporté au lendemain
mais c'était un mariage blanc ou six te
ramène ta sacoche vuitton statham
catherine trautmann ya 15 ans tu m'en
voudrais tu serais content ça m'a fait
de la peine c'est le mec très très fort
je suis dans une pizzeria on m'a piqué
mon set mais le même voilà je suis en
train de déjeuner là et tel quel il
arrive avec son portable
donc j'avais la sacoche au pied ouais
non mais non non ça sera pas possible
non hélas avec sa jambe il passe le pied
dans un bois non non non
la suisse a gelé vous parce que j'ai vu
la vidéo mais tu penses bien d'autres
personnes c'est pas exactement comme ça
je prends les noirs et de danse qui m'a
surtout fait de la peine c'est bourré
pas tellement là ça collait clé les
papiers le panda est un ordinateur et
des films de mon père que j'ai pas en
double et ça ça va bien emmerdés alors
là c'est panne d'essence et un petit
défi à propos de sa coche je vais te
montrer une photo je te mets au défi de
ne pas rire alors la photo on peut pas
la montrer parce que c'est une photo un
peu devenu c'est une personne qui se
fait mais oui les raser les testicules
n'avait par une femme
l'avenir cette rubrique en hockey
mais comment tu sais
[Applaudissements]
nrg lien mais c'est moi
on peut avoir c'est quoi mais comment tu
as eu ça on veut avoir un travail je
travaille non mais c'est quoi il parlait
voilà j'ai suivi petites interventions
rien de grave il fallait qu'il me passe
un cathéter parlait enfin bref les
nouvelles importantes et compagnie
seulement il faut tout raser et de
femmes comme j'ai pour vous épiler et là
le truc
puisqu'on est dans les détails qui est
très embêtant c'est qu'elle rasé donc
d'une main donc elle me demandait de moi
la m bon là avait dit à gauche je fais
des habs à droite mais commence à ussat
à et merci laurent pas
[Applaudissements]